y un descanso para luismar villarroel
con sus padres y sus dos hermanos esta
niña de 8 años dejó atrás su venezuela
natal para tratar de encontrar
estabilidad en colombia hoy ya puede
jugar como las niñas de su edad gracias
al proyecto jugar para soñar de este
refugio para migrantes venezolanos
colombia es desde hace años el principal
destino de las personas que huyen del
colapso económico y social de venezuela
cerca de 1.8 millones de inmigrantes
viven allí el gobierno de nicolás maduro
anunció la reapertura de su lado de la
frontera a principios de octubre el paso
se mantenía cerrado desde 2019 por una
crisis diplomática que desató el
opositor juan guaidó al intentar pasar
ayuda humanitaria hacia su país ante el
esperado aumento de las llegadas de
inmigrantes el comité internacional de
rescate se prepara para poder brindar
sus servicios sociales a las familias
que atraviesan colombia pero sin duda
esta reapertura pues va a aumentar el
flujo migratorio eso implicará que si
llegan más personas caminantes por
supuesto que pasen por nuestros puntos
de atención y puedan recibir la
asistencia humanitaria para louis marie
sus padres la ayuda y el soporte moral
fueron bien recibidos así o bien porque
hemos tenido orientación hemos hablado
con médicos por lo menos ayer tuvimos un
psicólogo nos han hablado bien nos han
dado este cómo podemos estar aquí en
colombia que debemos hacer el trato de
mano todas estas cosas yo debo gran
bendición para nosotros entre junio y
septiembre los niños constituyeron el 35
por ciento de los caminantes venezolanos
que llegaron a los centros del comité
internacional de rescate siendo
especialmente vulnerables al hambre la
deshidratación y la violencia así como
las consecuencias emocionales de la
travesía